こんにちははじめ社長です今回はこちらはキャン弾360度仮想現実没入機ボッツ
new
ぶーぶーっ
妄想
はいるんだな
はっはっはっはっはー
妄想へとしていきますデイトナで久しくしてないからねあ楽しみですよ
どうやってるんだろうけどチャンネルロックずーっと仮想空間ポツに千羽鶴コンテンツ
をスタートし本つにゅう本舗へ
没日本だ
スマホをセットするだけで目の前で仮想空が出現中で妄想デートはやめるは2つ早速術
挙げてみましょう
ちょっと説明書がありますポッツにうっていうもののネーミングセンスがすごいですよ
ね色々ととりあえずスマホがいるらしいですねスマホカバーを図のように置きます
巣箱遊馬ほぼを考えていけばいいのにね
カバーってもいいねここにスマホ
出てとすると思うんですっていうことだこうねそれでいいのも
ん
雑じゃいや雑雑雑買っただけでまだ実際やってないからなんともいえないですこれ本当
に目を入れるところあるのでこれを目に入れてと見れるって言うことですね
効果スマートフォンで何か設定しないと取れずが女っぽいですね
まずスマートフォンにインストールしましょう結局宿や評価が低いぞ
再生しても数秒で止まる罹病事1
ああああああ
8つ動画再生できませんだとこれお金をがふざけた
金返せホープっ
あくまでデビューですからね僕は知らないですよただ評価は
市郷中1.5ですあってもちゃんとか見かけました没妙な日目ですねはすげー
富士急ハイランドの360パンツあるのおっしゃら始まるってこと
始まると思っ
おねっあれ
とっ
えっう
は女の子がいるん
こんなんでこんなんん
こんにちはー
use on ん
あ
女の子だ
あ木積だおこんにちは
持った
にバーしたロックフック俺いるんだね
ウォッチか8位近い近い近い
わーっ今後のた近いぞあれあれば俺がいねぇんだろ
俺 nedo は今でちょっと説明すると俺がい目でで犬の飼い主ます
静かに静かに俺の飼い主の女のほかに行ってその女の子の友達の中二人子
アーサはいいねってもう俺登れがいるだからねこれの資格に来てなくこう抱っことかさ
れました
持っています
ね悪くて悪くねーぞ
ん
混ぜ戦慄迷宮の止まりますねこれガチの戦慄迷宮のバス
ホラー系のやつはやばいですね怖いですから奪う
こうはべき基礎
じゃ
ああっ
これやばいこれはやばいん
yeah
ame
わー
スマホ
動かずさんの360度見えて本当にその場にいるような感覚に僕は陥りました
なんでこの評価低いかなすっげー面白かったしいろんなコンテンツがとても楽しかった
ですけども
まぁ持って30分かな